I reject nation I'm Greg Alba John
Humphrey we're gonna watch the day from
a beautiful man named miles Fisher a
Saved by the Bell spoof this video is
very brand new it's from August that our
2011 since the sarcasm this video
request comes from a man named Jason
Dolan you see I don't know if you've
heard either one of us mentioned this
but we have this website patreon.com
slash the real rejects and over there we
do TV show reaction watch along for many
a show that includes attack on its hide
it and Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
my hair like a D me
Gotham Riverdale supernatural he does
music video coverage and we do weekly
Q&A 's and no we're not plugging
ourselves we're just telling you guys to
go over to our patreon and help us out
and it helps you out too with some extra
laps for the day ain't that nice but one
of our top reward tiers is whatever
video you're requesting must definitely
do and put up on the youtubes and today
comes from JD we saw this guy's American
Psycho vid it was funny
are you gonna play all okay mm-hmm say
work and I always do
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
mm-hm
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
like I look so familiar he's been
pretty sure you play some like Italian
guys every
[Music]
so except I'm so excited
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
because
screech
we
that's right is far to find out one of
the final destination movies that's sort
of an adjacent I was like final
destination it was gonna be my exact
comment hey Bella crossover we have all
been dreaming of since the 90s wow that
was very yeah not see that coming I was
a little bit worried that I wasn't gonna
get it cuz I'm not too familiar with
Saved by the Bell
I remember the opening credits as I
watched it right before filming but
other than that I was like I don't
really remember the show that well we
get all these jokes they're not even
playing any of them oh no I did not see
that big house in the first one with a
hair tied up against the locker that
I've falls over crutches that
splattering everything like it's so
great it's such a well timed perfectly
shaped just and the rest of the violent
bits that occurred to the ones are the
pencils like pencil stabbing moments and
like films or shows whatever that always
gets under my skin like I remember
there's a movie actually about school
called the faculty Robert Rodriguez film
and in the beginning of the movie
someone gets stabbed right through the
hand let's show that footage Jesus
Christ yes or in casino and Joe Pesci
stabs a guy with a pen her jugular
there's that Bourne Identity fight where
he fights out yeah we're not sure that
one wasn't exactly it's funny in context
but it still is like oh yes I was very
deserving boat is you because I actually
solve Saved by the Bell not altogether
long ago or at least the main show and I
was sitting there for the first part
going I know they did some musical
episodes I don't remember any of those
songs and people start dying and I was
very glad that this had its own set of
jokes coming out of the American Psycho
one like that one is so referential
they're recreating shots and yeah
specific moments and for this just to be
in the style of and I'm sure they're a
lot of Easter eggs for Saved by the Bell
fans and whatnot like when he comes into
her room and she's got the pills like
that's one of the most famous episode of
the show when Jesse's hooked on caffeine
and stuff yeah it's the whole I'm so
excited I'm so excited I'm so scared
hit like that's where that comes from
but there's little nuggets of Saved by
the Bell jokes here yeah yeah for sure
and yeah everyone's based on a character
and he's got the perfect like Zack
Morris like bleach swoop yeah yeah yeah
though once people start dying this this
busted me up I was not expecting that
I like when when they don't even hint
that the tones gonna change and then it
just does
cuz that's yes well Myles Fisher could
be in anything yeah you mean any era I
wish you did a friend's one what the by
the fountain in a really fun one I think
hey man hit up Jason Dolan and see if he
can float the idea make it happen I
think he knows him yeah this is the
perfect position to make this dream a
reality right now shut up garbage piles
why are you doing your civic duty now
don't you know some people have a
home-based business to run the world
needs to stop for our needs
Justin yourself a little bit okay who's
Nick da ghost ghost oh he's gonna look
so familiar to me
I've seen him in something that's right
he's Harvey Dent on Gotham yeah I've
been watching Gotham hey what do you
know I pulled that show earlier wait a
minute are all these people in final
destination 5 I think that guy dies
under a bunch of candle I'm pretty sure
they're all in final destiny sherita's
ask them for a favor to be a part of his
youtube channel there we go yeah they're
all look at that we put it together
people so go watch final destination 5
yeah after turning off this video all
makes so much more sense
yeah I saw PJ Byrne die on a compilation
of best kills in the final
disenfranchisement I mean by this point
in the video there's already so many
comments that people saying you know
they're all Lewiston Asian five idiots
so we are gonna set up a bunch of dummy
accounts to comment back well if you
stayed till this point in the video you
would just a record steer that figured
it out
what's Myles Fisher been up to lately
yeah he's no he's a working actor this
guy hmm good for him
proud of you miles you know I'm proud of
Jason Dolan I can't talk too much about
what's going on but had dinner with the
guy about a month ago he's got something
pretty major in production right now and
even even texted me the other day about
some awesome awesome developments he has
going on Jason Dolan I would give you a
sarcastic shout-out but I'm not going to
because you got us the camera that we're
filming on right now and even one of our
top pledges for a while you've meant a
lot to me I've been writing again a lot
in part inspiration to what you have
done for my life so I just wanted to say
thank you and I can't wait to rub your
bald head
all right I'm gonna be sarcastic though
listen Jason man I don't give a [ __ ]
about this camera
what don't leave me don't look at me
doctor you're the person in the room
with me Jason and I just want to let you
know that I missed your face and I miss
your spirit and I miss all of your very
many connections and friends because it
seems like you know everybody and that's
just always fascinating to find out
about and you know I just wish you would
return some of my dick pics because I'd
take a lot of time and effort to send
those and you know it's just really
weird to not have them you know
acknowledged at all dick pics John yeah
come on man you know I made that joke to
death already oh really I'm sorry I
invented dick pics really well I'm
taking them to the next level because
I'm introducing costumes expressive
lighting little like tab blows like
think of a glory hold and turn it on its
side and build a set around it you tryin
to get us D monetized yeah here at the
end of the video where they definitely
watch till to check those things
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell and download and
follow us on Twitter